ya estudiamos la curva y s con un poco
de detalle pero nada más con un pequeño
repaso lo que hace es relacionar la tasa
de interés real con el producto interno
bruto real déjame escribirlo como oye el
producto interno bruto real y la
relación pues había dos formas en las
cuales podíamos pensarlo uno es que la
tasa modifica la inversión lo cual
modifica el producto interno bruto o más
bien que las tasas modifican la
inversión planeada verdad lo cual cambia
el producto interno bruto real de modo
que si tenemos una tasa de interés alta
entonces no hay mucha inversión planeada
y así viendo la cruz keynesiana pues es
muy claro que si no hay una inversión
alta entonces el producto interno bruto
tampoco lo es bueno de modo similar si
tenemos una tasa de interés baja
entonces tenemos más inversión planeada
y por tanto tenemos un mayor producto
interno bruto así la curva y ese se veía
así se veía más o menos con pendiente
negativa y luego a poner con líneas
punteadas es esto de acá es la curva y
ese y quiere decir inversión y ahorros
savings en inglés esto de acá está mucho
más desde el punto de vista de la
inversión las tasas
la inversión pero también podemos verlo
desde otro ángulo podemos pensar como el
producto interno bruto real modifica el
ahorro lo cual modifica la tasa de
interés real en esa interpretación con
un nivel bajo de producto interno bruto
hay poquito ahorro o sea esencialmente
hay menos capital así para jugar con él
entonces es escaso y por tanto su precio
es caro como el precio del dinero es el
interés bueno ahorita es la tasa interés
real entonces este sería alto asimismo
también si el producto interno bruto es
alto y lo demás incluso el gasto de
gobierno lo dejamos fijo el gasto del
consumidor también va a aumentar pero no
va a aumentar tanto como el producto
interno bruto eso causa más ahorros y
por tanto más dinero para invertir
entonces el precio para pedir el dinero
prestado va a bajar lo cual es la tasa
de interés entonces son dos formas de
ver la verdad estoy acá es desde el
punto de vista del ahorro y acá esto es
desde el punto de vista de la inversión
por eso se llama la curva y ese
inversión y ahorros
bueno ahora de lo que quiero platicar es
de la curva l me voy a poner aquí en la
línea para separar porque después voy a
graficar sobre esta gráfica para que
después pensemos en un cierto nivel de
equilibrio de la tasa de interés real
con el producto interno bruto pero bueno
la curva lm para empezar lm quiere decir
preferencia por liquidez y oferta de
dinero preferencia por liquidez
liquidez y oferta de dinero oferta de
dinero la media de demonio otra vez
dinero en inglés preferencias porque
quieres suena como algo muy complicado
pero en realidad es una idea muy básica
y cate es lo siguiente la idea es que si
dejamos el dinero real constante quizás
deberías decir que es dinero real dinero
real
cuando hablamos de dinero real estamos
hablando del dinero que está en oferta
pero después de ajustarlo por la
inflación o sea podemos medir el dinero
real de la siguiente forma puede ser la
base monetaria hoy en los billetes
totales vamos a ponerle m 0 como m 0
dividido entre el ipc el índice de
precios para el consumidor así si el m 0
aumenta y el ipc también aumenta en la
misma cantidad en el mismo porcentaje
entonces no cambia el dinero real por
otro lado si m 0 aumenta sin que los
precios aumenten entonces el dinero real
aumenta y si el dinero permanece
constante pero los precios aumentan
entonces el dinero real baja vale
pero a lo que se refiere la preferencia
por liquidez es que si asumimos que
estoy acá es constante o sea para
cualquier nivel dado de esto lo voy a
poner aquí
suponemos constante entonces mientras
más actividad económica haya entonces va
a haber más demanda por ese dinero de
esta forma va a haber una mayor tasa de
interés real verdad las personas van a
estar dispuestas a pagar más por ese
dinero en términos reales o sea si por
acá tenemos digamos mucha actividad
económica entonces la gente va a querer
tener mucha moneda para realizar
transacciones para tener más
flexibilidad para el dinero por sí mismo
va a estar circulando mucho más va a
haber más demanda por ese dinero y si
hay más demanda por ese dinero entonces
las personas van a estar dispuestas a
pagar más para accesar a él o bien van a
pagarte más a ti para que les des el
dinero vale porque quieren tener
liquidez quieren acceso al dinero como
el precio del dinero es la tasa de
interés entonces de acuerdo a esto de
acá de acuerdo a la curva de preferencia
polic y dez entonces dejar el dinero
real constante hace que
el producto interno bruto es alto cuando
hay mucha actividad económica
toda la gente va a querer mucho dinero y
entonces su precio va a ser alto más
entonces tendríamos un punto por acá la
tasa de interés real sería alto por esta
cosa que se llama preferencia por
liquidez por otro lado si tenemos un
nivel bajo de economía ciento de la
gente va a decir bueno entonces no hay
mucha mucha demanda para la moneda hay
poquitas transacciones entonces vas a
tener que pagarle menos a alguien por
que te preste su dinero o bien si
quieres prestar lo vas a tener que
hacerlo a una menor tasa de interés
entonces de acuerdo con la preferencia
por liquidez si hay poco producto
interno bruto hay menor tasa de interés
así la curva lm
lm se vería más o menos así está de acá
es y efe punteada y la de acá es la lm
la que se ve hacia arriba cuando
gráficas estas dos en un mismo plano
cartesiano entonces la iese nos da una
relación entre la tasa de interés real y
como eso cambia la inversión y luego el
producto interno bruto o bien como el
pib afecte el ahorro y eso la tasa de
interés real entonces es una restricción
distinta a la lm verdad
acá nos dice que conforme las personas
tienen más y más actividad económica la
gente quiere tener más eso es
preferencia por liquidez si consideramos
ambas restricciones entonces llegamos a
un punto de equilibrio de por acá que es
un punto que satisface ambas
restricciones y ahí la economía está en
equilibrio con respecto a la tasa de
interés real y el producto interno bruto
real en tasa de interés real y producto
interno bruto muy bien ahora vamos a
pensar qué sucedería si el banco central
en el caso de méxico sería digamos el
banco de méxico pero le pongo el banco
central para que sea más en general si
el banco central decide imprimir más
dinero entonces imprimir más dinero
entonces por esta definición de acá
arriba de dinero real que sucedería a
muy corto plazo especialmente si nos
ponemos el casete de pensamiento que
inicia no a muy corto plazo los precios
no cambian aquí esto a muy corto plazo
no varía mucho de modo que si aumentamos
la oferta de dinero el dinero real
aumenta verdad todo a corto plazo
entonces le pongo el dinero real aumenta
así si el dinero real aumenta
esencialmente estamos aumentando
de dinero real y si aumentamos la oferta
de cualquier bien o cualquier servicio
verdad a cualquier nivel de demanda fijo
entonces la gente va a pagar menos que
sucede a unos para acá entonces para
cualquier nivel de producto interno
bruto hay más dinero de modo que el
precio va a ser menor el precio la tasa
de interés y así si el banco central
imprime dinero entonces el dinero real
aumenta suponiendo que los precios están
fijos porque son rígidos entonces si el
dinero real aumenta el precio de ese
dinero real disminuye para cualquier
nivel de producto interno bruto y
entonces concluimos que eso desplazaría
hacia abajo la curva lm entonces podemos
ver qué pasaría después con nuestro
equilibrio de tasas de interés y
producto interno bruto entonces en esa
situación la tasa de interés real bueno
la tasa de interés real en equilibrio
disminuye y eso qué causa esto causa
basado en este modelo una expansión del
producto interno bruto